and finally new rule someone has to tell
me how summer the time of year when we
traditionally give our brains a rest can
retain its specialness
if stupid season now runs all year round
[Applause]
how can you feel good about earning a
vacation for your mind if we've retired
from the job of thinking all together
you know it used to be that you worked
hard and behaved responsibly for most of
the year and then when June came
school's out brains out no reading
except for trashy novels on the beach no
studying no thinking no dress code the
movies were all stupid it was great
because you'd earned it even if you got
a summer job it was a weird gig you did
for a few months or as it's now called a
job now we have now ruined summer
because America insists on being peak
stupid at all times
our president is Donald Trump he's on
vacation all the time everything he does
is trivial how is my guilty pleasure
time of year supposed to outdo that how
can you enjoy casual Fridays when
everyone already dresses like [ __ ] all
the time
[Music]
flip-flops used to be a summer thing now
they're a year-round disgusting thing
it's not special to wear a swimsuit all
day when your everyday pants have an
elastic waistband I saw a guy at a
funeral in February
wearing cargo shorts and a who farted
t-shirt may he rest in peace
I mean time was that even casual
conversations in the summer adhered to
an unwritten code keep it stupid it's
summer we earned this don't be an
[ __ ] and start talking about serious
stuff keep it to isn't hot enough for
you when do you think the ice cream
truck is coming back with this and
what's the best way to get sand out of
your ass
and speaking of sand in your ass who can
forget summer romances all of us that's
who because that was the point of a
summer romance what happens in August
stays in August it was sudden exciting
and brief but now with apps like tinder
for straight people and Grindr for
Republicans
and the songs that you made love to in
the summer summer songs they're just
different you can do the moody stuff in
the winter but summer tend to keep it
light doo doo doo da da da looks like
they're the deepest a summer lyric ever
got was I like big butts and I cannot
lie but now all year round half the
songs have no lyrics
it's just noises people make during sex
and ODEs to the booty and the situation
with movies is even worse you know we
used to keep the sequel's
and the superhero [ __ ] confined to
the Sun that was the deal that no really
and then when September came the serious
movies came out films and we accepted
that we'd had our fun with robots and
car crashes and then in the fall we knew
it was time to go see the one where
Meryl Streep teaches gay Holocaust
survivors how to box
but now all year long as robots and
talking raccoons because I'm telling you
we are at maximum stupid
we don't read it's one thing to take the
summer off from heavy stuff and just
bring to the beach utter nonsense like
romance novels and whodunits and
Scientology at least it was a book of
some kind now educated people spend
their spare time on the phone matching
pretty colors in order to break
imaginary candy you know before the
internet the only escape from work was a
summer vacation but now escaping from
work it's as easy as closing the office
door and typing the words pornhub.com so
I don't know how this happened or when
exactly this stupid of fiying of the
whole year maybe it was the advent of
fox news maybe it was when we made stars
out of the Kardashians
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe it was the day John McCain decided
to let an ill-advised summer fling with
the ditzy [ __ ] last all the way into
November whatever it was we have got to
get summer back we've got to be able to
enjoy stupidity again hard-earned
respectable stupidity that's what my
goal is in the age of trumps